Hey,
wise crack,
jared here.
We saw coco last week,
every one cry,
and then once we got past that God awful
frozen short film,
they were all good tears.
Coco is a film filled with color,
both literally and in it's authentically
rich portrayal of Mexican culture,
but aside from the heartstring tugging
moments and gorgeous animation,
it also presents a really interesting
perspective on death that we don't often
see in cinema.
Will come this quick.
Take on cocoa and prepare for major
spoilers.
Also,
warning,
I'm going to put your all the Mexican
names.
I'm a Gringo Sumi first or recap seven.
Mexico young Miguel Rivera loves music
and wants to play guitar like his hero
or nested dela Cruz,
but music is banned in the Rivera family
since his great,
great grandpa left his family to pursue
a career in music.
After Miguel steals dela Cruz,
his guitar on Dia de Los Muertos,
he's transported to the realm of the
dead.
Believing dela Cruz is his great,
great grandfather Miguel ventures to
find him in hopes of receiving his
blessing to return to the living world.
Getting to this mega celeb is a hell of
a challenge,
but luckily his new pal hector agrees to
help him in exchange for putting up
Hector's photo on his family's,
a friend of a shrine with pictures of
our dancestors so he's not forgotten and
is able to visit the land of the living
to see his daughter.
Stuff happens and it turns out that
Miguel's great,
great grandfather is not Ernesto,
but hector,
who's beloved daughter is Miguel's
great.
Grandmother,
Coco dela Cruz,
murdered hector stole his songs,
his guitar,
and ultimately his chance to be
remembered by his family.
Miguel returns to the land of the living
sparks,
Coco's memory of her father by singing
protectors.
Picture on the agenda and they all live
or die happily ever after,
as evidenced by the number of hipster
sugar skull tattoos I see in Los
Angeles.
Many Americans are fascinated by dia de
los muertos and Coco isn't the first
animated film that makes use of that
setting.
In 2014,
Twentieth Century Fox put out a movie
called the book of life,
which also features a boy who was shoes.
Family tradition to pursue music is
transported to the land of the dead on
Dia de los Muertos and requires the help
of his ancestors to return to the world
of living.
Even though these films feature similar
plots,
they couldn't be more different and
their portrayal of debt in the book of
Life Minolos dead ancestors basically
exist only to assist in his journey and
give the producers and excuse to cast
ice cube in your story that is presented
as something static once your dad.
That's it.
If you're remembered by your family,
you get to party and if you're
forgotten,
you're a sad sack,
but either way you're dead.
Coco elevates this concept by
introducing a second kind of death
beyond the biological be symbolic death
of being forgotten once there's no one
alive who remembers you,
you disappeared from the land of the
dead,
passing away a second time.
That second death is brought on solely
through relationships to others in
cocoa.
It's People's memories that mark the
difference between life and debt,
and interesting way to think about this
is through the lens of philosophers.
John Beaudry,
who talks about death as a kind of
social relation,
the Western cultural understanding of
death has been filtered through science
to the point where we now think of death
as a primarily biological phenomenon.
Once your heart stops and your fingers
start rotting,
your dad,
boatyard compares this to certain non
Western cultures in which death has a
symbolic relation of exchange with the
living in these cultures,
not only his death,
something both given and received by the
living,
but the dead can give and receive as
well.
Cocoa Explores this system of mutual
exchange between the living and the
dead.
Miguel needs the help of his relatives
to return to the land of living,
but they need his help as well.
Hector makes a deal with Miguel to bring
his photo to the a friend that in
exchange for his assistance in getting
home and on Dia de los Muertos,
the other living characters interact
with their ancestors.
Despite not being able to see them that
eat the grave sites bring offerings and
authentically honor those who have
passed.
It's only the exchange that occurs on
Dia de los Muertos that prevents the
dead from experiencing the second,
honestly way more terrifying death that
happens when you're no longer
remembered.
Boatyard says that in most western
societies that kind of two way exchange
between the living and the dead doesn't
exist.
The dead aren't a group that the living
interact with and the more society is
obsessed with rationality,
the less of a role dead people play
among the dead people we do remember we
put them on money and on posters and
learned about them in history class,
but we don't think of it in terms of a
relationship.
We don't expect anything from the dead
and we don't offer them anything either.
Even the idea of this sounds pretty
wild,
but this removal of the dead from our
social interactions changes the shape of
a culture.
Eventually Boatyard says,
when the dead don't interact with the
living,
they become obliterated.
We see this obliteration in Coco when
individuals stop existing once they no
longer have living relatives to
participate in that exchange of
remembrance and celebration and Care
Church,
our own,
the only person we witness experiencing
that second death doesn't leave a body
behind the way he certainly did in his
biological dad.
His skeleton fades and all that slept.
Defendant is a guitar and a bunch of
junk in a Hammock,
but while memory might be enough to save
the dead from permanent extinction,
they suffer when they aren't able to
return to the living and interact with
their family.
Just had a really hard the other night.
Could we be using them equal right now?
Memory matters,
but the living have to be willing to
give something more than that.
For Baudrillard.
This give and take between life and
death would mean that dying and being
born are not necessarily opposites.
They're part of this big system of
exchange as well,
and death can be traded for live via
social interactions,
and although he's not talking about
Coco,
although we wish he was,
hector's shift from being forgotten to
being celebrated among his descendants
is in a sense a kind of rebirth.
Although he hadn't quite crumbled into
dust yet.
He's at risk of being obliterated.
The moment coco forgets him and the
spark of her memory brings him back to
life.
Even though biologically he's still dead
as a doornail.
When Coco herself eventually dies,
she's reunited with her parents in the
land of the dead.
She's their child again.
Even though she looks about twice their
age combined with them,
she makes her journey back to the land
and living for their yearly visit.
The fruitful exchange of Dia de los
Muertos still involves cocoa,
but now from the other side of your
friend up,
there is a reason that people cry when
Miguel sings.
Remember me at the end of the film.
It's a moment of connection between Coco
and her long gone father,
but it's also a command to all of us,
not to forget the dead.
The performance of the song brings
symbolic life back to hector,
but the words of the song itself
celebrate the importance of life beyond
death.
For a kids movie that's pretty damn
profound.
Although coming from Pixar,
we wouldn't expect anything less.
Coco gives us all the good stuff's
sweeping musical scores and shots so
colorful.
It's like shooting up a box of Crayola
is,
but it also makes us think is true death
when your heart stops beating or when
there's nothing left,
if you in people's memories is the mark
you leave on the world.
Really it's own kind of immortality.
Thanks for watching guys.
I hope you love Coco as much as we did.
Piece.
Thanks for watching wise crack.
If you don't want your future family to
remember you looking like a Schlub,
you're going to want to let dollar shave
club help you out.
For a limited time,
dollar shave club wants to give
wisecrack fans and exclusive deal to get
their starter set for just five bucks.
When you go to dollar shave
club.com/wise
crack.
If you're like me,
you don't know a thing about razors and
you're so sick of paying insane prices,
so usually just skip shaving entirely,
but dollar shave club doesn't want us to
go to these extreme measures and they'll
ship high quality razors directly to
your door at incredible prices.
For just five bucks and three Shipping
Dollar Shave Club will send you their
starter set.
Your first box will include their
executive razor,
a full sleeve of cartridges,
and three trial size versions of their
freshest and most popular products.
Shave butter bodywash and one wipe
Charlie's butt wipes.
After that,
razors are just a few bucks a month.
I've tried tons of razors in my day to
combat my chronic neck beard and none of
them have combined the value and the
quality like the ones from dollar shave
club.
Plus,
it's not just razors and bought wipes.
They've got lotions,
hair gels,
toothpastes and more.
Treat yourself or friends with gift
memberships and he gift cards,
so head over to dollar shave
club.com/wise
crack who starts saving time and money
and get your exclusive $5 starter kit.
Thanks to dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this video.
We've got tons of great stuff on the way
y'all including videos on up wonder
woman and more so if you haven't
already,
be sure to subscribe and ring that bell.
Catch you all next time.
Peace.